good morning Hank it's Tuesday September
23rd which means that Paper Towns comes
out in 22 days oh my god
oh boy Hank I'm seriously stressing the
only way to get the puffs under control
frankly was to get a haircut and even
that can't keep it fully under control
the puff is like a wild heart Hank it
cannot be broken but just because I'm
stressed out doesn't mean that it's not
Tuesday question Tuesday the day that I
answer real questions from real
nerdfighters when does Paper Towns come
out October 16th have I not said that
enough oh my god I haven't said that it
up October 16th October 16th October
16th October 16th and you say Hank talks
faster than I do
why are you coming to Dallas Washington
DC Tucson Arizona Tempe New Mexico okay
first off Tempe is not a New Mexico if
you want us to come to your hometown you
need to tell us the correct state it in
second off over the course of the next
five to six weeks I promise you that I
am going to every place I possibly can
but nerdfighters sometimes you've got to
meet us halfway don't ask why aren't you
coming to Washington DC ask what can I
do to get to Charlottesville Virginia
don't ask why aren't you going to Tempe
New Mexico ask yourself do I live in
Tempe or do I live in New Mexico and
then based on the information you've
acquired find out the nearest spot on
the tour and come to it also bring your
friends unless you're too much of a
nerdfighter to have friends in real life
in which case bring your bullies are you
going to be doing any events before your
tour starts yes and thank you for asking
this Friday and Saturday I'm going to be
in the Twin Cities of Minnesota and then
on October 1st I'm going to be doing a
public event in Berlin and not like
Berlin New Mexico but like Berlin
Germany details in the sidebar also
there are several new events in the Tour
de nerdfighting you can find out all the
details as they come in at nerdfighters
calm but I will tell you the names of
the cities that we are definitely going
to and this is it New York Boston
Indianapolis Columbus Atlanta Orlando
Miami Naperville Chicago Phoenix Seattle
San Francisco Los Angeles Plano Oklahoma
City st. Louis Indianapolis Louisville
Knoxville Gaston Newport News
Charlottesville Lancaster Westport
Pittsburgh Ann Arbor Racine Ames Kansas
City in the Twin Cities so Hank that's
how fast I can talk I know Fresno can
talk faster but can you are these events
free and open to the public yes entirely
do we need tickets
no except in a couple of instances you
should RSVP to the event in Boston
number in the sidebar by the way Julia
Nunes will not be at the event in New
York but she will be at the event in
Boston I think I've decided that the
official tagline for that show is oh yes
there will be Nunes do you know the girl
on the cover of Paper Towns no not
personally but I did help pick her out
her name is Dana she's Canadian and
she's awesome have you picked a
punishment yet Hank we don't get to pick
punishments nerdfighters do it seems
like the two most popular options for
punishments are one do Brotherhood 2.0
style vlogging from one month
yikes or to dress up like a peep for
Halloween and hand out peeps on the
street nerdfighters you can vote for
your favorite punishments and comments
if I order the book online which color
will I get you will get random color
which is arguably the best color of all
because the basic idea of the cover
design is that each cover represents a
Miss imagining of the person involved
and since both covers are fundamentally
wrong neither can be superior I can't
come to your show because I'll be in
school and or it's a school night no
those aren't technically questions but
I'm still happy to answer them I didn't
schedule any of the events for during
school because then no one would have
come and I know that many of the events
are on a school night but I'm sure that
you'll be able to tell your parents that
since it's you know book related you
should totally be allowed to come and if
you can't convince them just have them
email me and all convince them will we
finally get to see the Yeti yes the Yeti
will be at many of the events unless of
course I've been making her up all this
time hank dftba nerdfighters hope to see
a lot of you in Minneapolis on Friday
and Saturday and some of you in Berlin
on October 1st and John don't stress out
so much everything's gonna be fine also
stop talking to yourself it's weird Oh
PS from Blue John nerdfighters who are
attending events in Minneapolis there
will be a pretty amazing surprise there